sometimes a dream almost whispers your
instincts your
human personal intuition always
whispers it never shouts what what calls
to me
is not whether a film is going to make a
gazillion dollars
what calls to me is is there an a a deep
urge
in the center of myself that only that
film will release
because look at how nice his films are
i mean just they're nice they're about
love
they're about wonder they're about you
know good
things they're not about rotten awful
things and that's because that's what
stephen responds to
who you are is original it just is
because you're not tom you're not me and
you're not your
best friend and you're not your teacher
you're not your parents you are you and
because of that you
do have every bone in your body as an
original bone in your conscience
shouts here's what you should do
while your intuition whispers here's
what you could do
listen to that voice that tells you what
you could do
[Music]
if i had to single out one area to which
i have an utter devotion
it would be with my preoccupation with
the idea
and the fight to still believe in the
idea when so many others around you just
don't get it
and the challenge of staying interested
in one single idea for sometimes years
and the struggle not to contaminate that
idea after
months and years of obsessing over it
when i was in my early teens i stayed up
all night writing a screenplay
and felt something to this day i swear i
could not get enough of
it was as close to the feeling of flying
as i have ever had
you know what i mean when when you're
trying to get the
words on paper and your three thoughts
ahead of yourself and it's a race
to get it all down before it goes back
to where that's ever that stuff
originally comes from
and it was called inspiration
and i actually made a movie from that
script i wrote all night and it was
called fire light
and it was truly an awful movie
but the process was what it was all
about
the experience of that obsessive focus
of having an idea and actually being
able to photograph it
that's been the magic potion for me ever
since when you have a dream
and the dream isn't something you dream
then it happens the dream is something
you never knew was going to come into
your life
dreams always come from behind you not
not right between your eyes it sneaks up
on you
but when you have a dream it doesn't
often come at you screaming
in your face this is who you are this is
what you must be for the rest of your
life
sometimes a dream almost whispers and
i've always said to my kids
the hardest thing to listen to your
instincts your
human personal intuition always
whispers it never shouts very hard to
hear
so you have to every day of your lives
be ready to hear
what whispers in your ear it very rarely
shouts
and if you can listen to the whisper and
if it
tickles your heart and it's something
you think you want to do for the rest of
your life
then that is going to be what you do for
the rest of your life
and we will benefit from everything you
do thank you very much
emotional quotient in in every film of
yours and
is emotion close to you and what is the
deciding factor
is business more important for you or
the emotional factor in a story
you know the emotional factor in the
story always because you have been
breaking the business barriers very
often
but but what what what what calls to me
is not
whether a film is going to make a
gazillion dollars what calls to me
is is there an a a deep urge in the
center of myself
that only that film will release and
and then and then exorcize and and
that's the only condition i'll direct a
movie
uh if i'm doing a sequel of course if
i'm doing the lost world the secret to
jurassic park
of course i know that the bar has been
raised because if it
doesn't make this x amount of money
everybody thinks it's a failure
and there's that added pressure of great
expectation
the indiana jones series they're not
sequels but
on all the other three indiana jones
films that i've directed
there's a tremendous level of
expectation and that's
nerve wracking but but
the fact that those movies are
successful and make a lot of money
isn't why i decided to direct sequels to
the indiana jones series
i mean when i'm looking at student films
or i'm looking at first-time directors
short films
i'm not looking for how great the camera
is i mean so many people
i can look at any tv commercial and know
that there are directors out there that
can place a camera
and sell a product because they tell a
story that
holds together it is compelling and and
and original
and that's the secret you know i i i'm
more interested in the storyteller
doesn't know anything about where to put
the camera
than someone who knows everything about
the camera but nothing about the story
process
what advice would you give to kids who
want to make movies oh
it's a good question because i would i
would tell kids who want to make movies
to make movies
when i was a kid the only way i could
make a movie was borrow money from my
father and
borrow his eight millimeter movie camera
and borrow the money because film was
expensive the film and the developing of
the film was expensive then
today you can take your telephone your
your your cell phone
you can make a movie on that if it's a
really cool movie that's funny and it's
dramatic or whatever you can post it on
youtube
so it's a lot easier for kids today to
get started and follow their passion
and pursue their hearts you know desire
to be a filmmaker
because the tools that were less
available
to my generation growing up are
completely available to yours
so there's no reason why you can't
express who you are through
video spielberg spent 30 million dollars
making 1941
an over-budget sophomoric attempt at
comedy
the film was considered an artistic and
financial flop
by both critics and moviegoers and
marked his first
and so far only crashing failure
i was low i was depressed i was not
feeling good we'll catch out of it
uh starting just throwing myself back
into my work again and starting to
work on raiders
[Music]
burned by the disaster of 1941 spielberg
redeemed himself in the eyes of the
movie industry
with the success of raiders of the lost
ark
indiana jones was the hero of raiders he
could he won the lady and
got the treasure and i wanted to be the
behind the scenes hero who brought the
film in for under schedule under budget
well what you choose to do next is what
we call in the movies the character
defining moment
now these are moments you're very
familiar with like in the last star wars
the first
force awakens when rey realizes the
force is with her
or indiana jones choosing mission over
fear by jumping into a pile of snakes
now in a two-hour movie you get a
handful
of character defining moments but in
real life
you face them every day life is one
straw
strong long string of character defining
moments and i was lucky
that at 18 i knew what i exactly wanted
to do but i didn't know
who i was i
how how could i and how could any of us
because for the first 25 years of our
lives
we are trained to listen to voices that
are not our own
parents and professors fill our heads
with wisdom and information and then
employers and mentors
take their place and explain how this
world really works
and usually these voices of authority
make sense but sometimes
doubt starts to creep into our heads and
into our hearts and even
when we think that's not quite how i see
the world
it's kind of easier just to nod an
agreement and go along and for a while
i let that going along to find
my character because i was repressing my
own point of view
because like in that nielsen song
everybody was talking at me so i
couldn't hear the echoes of my mind
and at first the internal voice i needed
to listen to
was hardly audible and it was hardly
noticeable
kind of like me in high school but then
i started paying more attention
and my intuition kicked in and i want to
be clear that your intuition is
different from your conscience
they work in tandem but here's the
distinction your conscience
shouts here's what you should do
while your intuition whispers here's
what you could do
[Music]
listen to that voice that tells you what
you could do
nothing will define your character more
than that
what i find with you is that it's truly
what interests you
what it is you want to know at that
point what it is you want to see
and i think it's okay that a first-time
filmmaker
being so inspired by movies and music
videos and any kind of music or media
um can make a derivative film it's okay
that your first videos and your first
attempts at telling a story are
derivative are
obviously influenced by something that
you know
that you saw last week and you want to
kind of do a version there's nothing
wrong with learning the abcs running
your craft
by being derivative but at some point
you're going to need to find your
natural voice
and find a way to give voice to who you
are and who you are by the way
who you are is original it just is
because you're not tom you're not me and
you're not your
best friend and you're not your teacher
not your parents you are you
and because of that you do have every
bone in your body is an original bone
it's sometimes trying to figure out how
to express your own original
analogy and that sometimes takes a
number of years to figure yourself out
the shark broke down
uh because of you know mechanical
problems actually beyond our control
and i just went ahead and made the movie
anyway using the ocean as the nemesis or
as at least
as the threat and i think it cranked up
the suspense a lot more
that shark was a complete prima donna
and and
just would not come out of its dressing
room this dress room happened to be the
atlantic ocean
but we could not get the shark to make
an appearance and i think in a sense
because the shark didn't show up the
sharks uh
a no-show saved the movie you're gonna
need a bigger boat
people say you know gee the movie's
really scary because my imagination saw
more of the shrug than you actually
showed me
well part of that was was intentional
because i wanted i thought i could scare
people
with just the ocean line and and just
the mystery of what's under the murky
water but also
the darter shark wouldn't come out of
his dressing room for months i mean the
thing never worked
the shark on jaws works much better on
the universal tour than it ever worked
on martha's vineyard when i made draws
a.t was the gift that came from the
heavens for me i was in tunisia
making raiders of the lost ark and we
were setting up a shot
and i was picking up fossils in the
desert which used to be the bottom of
the ocean
millions of years ago we were out there
in the nephtha desert i was picking up
uh
and i was remembering the end of close
encounters
when richard dreifus goes up into the
mother ship and just before that the
little alien comes down
and does the hand signs to francois
truffaut
and it just hit me out of the sky i
thought what if the alien had stayed
behind on earth
what if he didn't what if it was a kind
of foreign exchange dreyfus goes away
and the alien stays and then suddenly
this whole story hit me like a ton of
bricks
and which was really a story about my
mom and dad when they got divorced and
how i felt as a kid
wanting a friend like that to fill the
void
in my life and and and all these things
came pouring in and i actually
put the story together in a couple of i
think a couple of days
and then it happened to be that harrison
ford's
wife melissa matheson who had written
the black code written the black
stallion was on the set with harrison
and i just want to get this thing
written and i love black style i said
hey melissa you want to write this she
said no
and then harrison talked her into it and
then she said yes eventually and
and she did a tremendously wonderful
screenplay
you